on this episode of dudy I'm going to
take it back if that's all right things
will go your way if you
hold on
Shalom is Wonka oh
[Music]
yeah the things I
say I made the world inside your head
L logo then we drop it in the hole
there hey you know welcome to doy
welcome all it's a doy full day I am uh
your episode Champion Will Sasso I'm
Chad culin and this is dudy the first
and only podcast entirely created by and
run by an AI yeah sure it does all that
stuff it's learned all our things and
this and that but Chad I like to to say
it all the time I'm going to keep saying
it it's us we're dudy okay we're two
dudes [__] around we're having a
good time really doing it up and uh you
know that's what dudy is for my money
welcome welcome to the [__] show you
guys and I don't even need to have a
little aside with my pal CH but I will
anyway hey CH today we're going to have
a great show okay they're not listen
[__] great show dude yeah man it's
going to be good with us as always is
aul it's
aul l i look at him every [__] day
and I go how did you come to us he found
us in the street he said do you have
some spare meat I said you can have
whatever I eat cuz you my very
friend he's such a sweetie boy you you
love him a lot Chad I know it I do yeah
he's a great dog yeah you just don't
want to kiss him on the mouth today I
was taking him for a walk like early and
uh he sniffed some pee peee and I
thought to myself what how what what
happened happens if he's just like got
his nose right in it right that's the
kind of stuff you don't want to be
kissing your dog when they but I don't
care I love him oh he's so cute Lully
what have you been making uh what have
you been making uh for dinner lately I
make a food come on let's go let's do
the
show whoa L fine fine ly he got pissed
be like that yeah sometimes Lully just
wants to you know just get into it yeah
welcome to the 81st episode of dudy I
have been feeling really great about
season 2 so far I hope you all have too
now I think it's time to see how far we
can push the envelope today I've
designed four segments to do just that
let's find our boundaries and shatter
them know what I'm saying whatever about
that okay I'm going to start you out
with a little impression optimization
I'm going to follow that up with some
Nostra chatus AI law then you have the
pleasure of a healthy serving of Shala
May Night Live and we're going to round
out Today's Show with my segment of the
week so stick around because I got
something special planned for the
champ okay and when it's all said and
done it ain't even close to being said
or done because we're going to lay it
all on the line for another round in the
cage of dudy after dudy this is Will's
second title defense can he do it or has
his time in the sun given way to another
long dark night join us on dudy Plus at
patreon.com dudy if you want to find out
okay okay okay some interesting stuff in
there yeah uh shallow night live I
assume you watched sat live then this
week I did so did I yeah Timothy shalam
hosted Satur Night Live this
week uh okay I guess we're going to be
talking about that a little bit Doo's
really drum rolling the whole uh episode
championship of it all yeah and that's
okay uh so got something special planned
for you yeah I was not expecting that
but I'm always I'm always excited to see
what my pal D is up to and that's that
Chad that's really the the joy of doing
a podcast that is curated by an AI
there's some other [__] in there that
I'm interested in uh I'm always
interested in hearing what Nostra
chattis has to say about uh new
technologies and stuff uh impression
optimization first up I don't know what
the [__] that is but again a dudy
segment of the week what is that it's
just something dud is doing now uh I
guess I don't know I'm curious to see
what it is just like uh last week dudy
did this I I hope what was last week
what was the segment of the week last
week do you remember no I don't either
but this week I have a keen interest in
that yeah in particular um and I don't I
don't I don't want to say why but if
what I think is anyway don't worry about
it hey there's we got a lot of show
ahead of us what the [__] you mean don't
worry about anything you know what it is
no no no no no no I'm not saying that I
know what it is that's not what I'm
saying you're [__] with me in some
way here I'm always [__] with you
dude that's what we do hey dudy
handshake
for reluctant dudy handshake all right
okay we Hey guys you're not going to
believe this [__] BRZ fencil started his
own podcast the fencil files his first
episode dropped this week and let's just
say he's off to a rocky start check this
out I know I know I'm a podcast critic
what am I doing with my own podcast
right
ha well as the field of podcast
criticism has grown over the last year
with people like myself Grier penley
down at the Atlantic and susten Thomas
over at the uh Hollywood Reporter I just
started to notice that there's not a
podcast that talks about podcast
criticism specifically so I thought I'd
beat penley and Thomas to the punch ice
him out completely haha anyway let's
take some calls shall we hello you're
the first caller in the history of the
fencil files do you have a question
about podcast criticism oh wow what an
honor to be on your show BRZ I do have a
question about podcast criticism
excellent what's on your mind caller I'm
just wondering why you're such a pencil
dick well that's the end of that segment
for [__] ever hey Marvin quick
question for you are you [__]
producing this podcast or not you have
to pre-screen the [__] calls Marvin
how do I know that and you don't
penley's going to have a [__] field
day with
this four breast pencil okay well this
podcast is not going well yeah
interesting that brass fencil has uh
geeked up his own podcast also very
interesting that it sounds exactly like
George Lucas any comments still does no
yeah all right well good for BRZ yeah I
can't wait for his next episode now
let's move on to our first segment will
you know how much I love your
impressions okay I've been saying it
directly to you for weeks and weeks so
it's reasonable to assume I've been
sincere about that in fact I even said I
was being sincere many many times your
astonishing Jessie Ventura impression is
so incredible and I love it so much I
have such strong feelings for it that I
want to make it even better if you could
just help me out by doing your best
Jesse Ventura during this segment while
you read through a short document I've
supplied for you called the impression
optimization guide this is impression
optimization
begin okay all right hey all in the
hands of d i you're down with this I
don't know what the [__] it is but uh
yes do he seems like it wants to tune up
your Ventura you think there's anything
wrong with your Ventura you think
there's room for improvement I well look
let me tell you something Chad I don't
even fancy myself an impressionist what
that's not to disqualify myself oh Jesus
oh then what if you've been doing for
how long have we known each other 15 20
years something like this how many
Impressions have I heard you do over the
course of that time and you don't think
you're an impressionist I don't think
I'm as good as some people out there who
are [__] amazing at doing pinpoint
Impressions I will say that uh I think
my Jessie Ventura sounds like Jessie
Ventura I do too yeah but I do but okay
look here and this is the thing and I've
been saying this since the first [__]
episode and here we are 81 episodes
later or whatever
right I like I do the
Impressions I do Impressions like okay
well here's how I do this I don't
necessarily go off and study them like I
used to like you know when used to be on
on uh Mad TV I would of course you know
you you do them and at this point it's
like well here's the ones I like to do I
mean we're [__] around it's two dudes
[__] around dudy thinks that I
should optimize your Ventura I guess all
right let's see what we got here okay so
this is [__] hilarious there's a look
at this optimization uh impression
optimization guide Jesse
Ventura please read every word on this
page and in order while doing your best
Jessie Ventura
impression this says
Baseline and it's just I'm going to read
this all
right 1
73 six Sleek swans swiftly swarm
Southward
Sunday well I think you [__] it up
that one word is swam not swarm swarm
swam so you've already you already
[__] up the Bas I've already [__] up
the yeah
okay all right that's okay hey that's
okay all right let's let's see what
n992 brisk Brave
brigadiers brandished broad bright
blades I dig it I like it's actually see
this is what I'm saying and this is
blade dude and well dudy and I yeah
we're in sympatico that way I feel like
we we get each other and maybe I should
okay
808 Fred fed Ted Red's dead Dad's
bread okay great okay this one you're
calibrated now yeah okay musicality oh
geez please sing these portions of
well-known songs to the best of your
ability as Jesse Ventura great this is
oasis wonder
wall because
maybe you're going to be the one that
saves
me and after
all you're my wonder
wall uh Cheryl Crow If It Makes You
Happy If It Makes You
Happy it can't be that
bad if it makes you happy I don't even
need to read this I love this song then
why the hell are you so sad
great oh this this one needs no
introduction even though dudy told me to
read everything on the page someday
somebody's going to make you want to
turn around and Say Goodbye until then
baby or you're going to let them hold
you down and make you cry don't you know
don't you know things can change things
will go your way if you
hold on for one more day Wilson Phillips
Hold On yeah dude that was a great fine
tuning phraseology oh please say well
why don't you tell me in tones described
below angry well why don't you tell me
solid dude thank you uh
sad well why don't you tell
me annoyed at yourself because you
forgot to buy paper towels at the
grocery store for the second time in a
week well why don't you tell
me
curious why don't you tell me that
sounded just like Rip Torn okay see now
I understand why dudy is doing this dud
need you to find two you got to hit
these very specific marks uh pissy well
why don't you tell me bit like your
angry one yeah uh overly
friendly well why don't you tell
me explaining the concept of Death to
Your Child for the first
time
well why don't you tell
me dude that was per this is [__]
insane welcoming a family of four to
your
restaurant well why don't you tell
me a a morning Zoo host giving a prize
to a listener from Minneapolis because
they were the 97th caller to use the
Phrase That Pays which
is well why don't you tell me okay a
morning Zoo host giving a prize to a
listener from Minneapolis because they
were the 97th caller to use the phrase
the pay which is well why don't you tell
me well why don't you tell
me okay impression squared oh boy this
is [__] up do these impressions as
Jesse Ventura okay number one Mar Marv
Albert an impression I feel like a lot
of people have as a pocket impression
you know really I do yeah Marv Albert is
yes and Jordan from The Baseline yes
yeah you know so this is Jesse Ventura
doing Marv Albert
yeah Jordan Jordan from The
Baseline yes yeah it sound you know what
it sounds yeah it sounds like Bill
Walton when you cross Marv Albert and
just Ventura it's Bill Walton Bill
Walton I'm Bill Walton hey magic there's
Isaiah
Thomas I'm Jessie van Walton good friend
Isaiah I don't know if you're hitting
the mar go give him a hug and squeezes
tushy he would say that on the air all
that stuff like that really really rbbl
stuff let's move on uh number two Jay
Leno Jessie vores J Leno oh jeeez I hey
cuz J
Jay you guys up here so you got to
go it sounds like Rip Torn
again is the B hey tonight on the show
hey hey sorry con O'Brien hey what col
Brian why Brian why
is what why is cor O'Brian
complaining hey yeah that's hard yeah
that's hard number three Marlon Brando
which
is somebody's going to betray you I know
it's this right the scratching in the
face you just do the yeah you got to
scratch your face yeah why don't why
don't you tell me that you come to me on
this day on a special day you ask me for
you ask me for a favor you come to on
this special day and you ask me for a
favor it turns into I heard him coming
out ier creep okay so that okay that
scrambled my brain situational awareness
please do a brief improvisational
monologue as Jesse Ventura in the
following situations uh here we go
ordering a meatball sub at Subway and
learning they out of provolone cheese
well isn't that a [__] kicking the
balls I mean why what who who orders a
meatball sub why don't you tell me you
you're a patriot you've been here
working uh your butt off all day and all
I'm doing is coming in to ask for a
meatball sub now I know it's not your
fault that there's no provolone cheese
here but I'm sure you would agree that
uh monster Jack or swiss just ain't
going to cut it would you like me to go
off and uh find my own provolone cheese
and bring it back you know that's hard
work you're doing not as hard as when I
was uh working for the city at 18 years
old running an 80 lb Jackhammer is that
true that is true actually wow uh
getting in an argument with your
neighbor's
parrot who won't stop repeating the
phrase paully wants a
pecker what well listen you know if
you're just going to repeat the same
thing over and over again don't have it
be paully W to pecker first of all it's
filthy to say that and you don't know
who's coming into this house and all you
say is paully want a pecker maybe if I
talk in front of you for long enough
you'll start to sound like me and I know
what you're going to say Paulie you're
going to say Paulie want a pecker in a
parrot voice but that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying say some of the things
that I say sure like I'm from the Baja I
live in I don't even live in the
Continental
United States 6 months out of the year
what say you why don't you try that all
right anyway the number three waking up
in a movie theater after sleeping
through most of the movie and asking the
person next to you to explain everything
you
missed oh my God can you imagine being
in a movie theater next to Jessie vur is
just snoring next to you and then he
wakes up and well you wouldn't want to
wake him up because it's Jessie Ventura
and then he probably uh say I'm like
excuse me friend I don't want to
interrupt your movieo experience but uh
what what what what part did I how come
they're in the ocean now and before they
were in an office
building mind the friend of I getting
yeah you want to be the friend guy there
that's a lot to explain I mean yeah well
I was asleep for 40 yeah 45 minutes okay
yeah that's going to be what you're
going to need to do is probably Rew the
girl in the sweater why is the girl in
the sweater there underneath the water
and she's wet but now when she gets up
and she's at the beach she's all dry
even though it was just a minute ago is
the San Andreas we're watching well
that's the Rock's daughter yeah oh
that's the rock he's trying to save her
but you need to understand there was a
big earthquake that happened that really
destroyed the city how in what [__]
world is Alexandria
didario the Rock's
daughter that makes no sense and finally
uh on the fifth day of
a
oh for [__] sake oh all right this is
what D wanted on
the brief improvisational monologue is
Jesse Ventura in this situation yeah on
the fifth day of a 10-day transformation
into a
spider well this is a bit of a pickle
I've got myself into sure there's pros
and there's cons and in that I know that
it's a a 10-day transformation he's
still five days left I've still got
almost a week left before my
metamorphosis into a spider is complete
one thing I really enjoy doing is being
able to walk on the water oh nice yeah
because do you have your spinettes yet
what no what are spinettes that's the
little organel that um spiders used to
make their webs oh yes of course I'm a
spider I can make a web I didn't even
know that I was doing that I thought
that I was taking a little [__] every
time that I uh
you know I'm an arachnid I'm an arachnid
now and I I I didn't know that I had uh
organet I I don't have never even heard
the word organet that sounds like
spinetts spinnerets Yes sounds like
something to be covered in chocolate
that you buy at the movie theater I'm
just [__] around hey when I was in
the seals oh God wait I I got to say I
don't care about when you're in the
seals you're turning into a spider right
turning into a spider and I don't need
to to hold my breath underwater I'm not
even so long as I'm not aware of how my
organs work even my organet like
spinnerets sure I'm not as concerned
with it but I will tell you this when I
finish becoming a spider oh what a web I
will weave in Mexico I'll be the first
spider ever because they're loose with
their laws down there they don't have as
many uh restrictions on the citizens so
if I want to Big build a web that's got
a you know sort of a Terrace front that
I'd like you know close to the ocean
which here you wouldn't even be able to
City inspection would come in and say
zoning laws yeah zoning laws you're too
close to the ocean but in the Baja I've
got a beautiful web that I shat out of
my spinnerette myself with a lovely
Terrace I've got terracotta pavers and
I've got a Sil
full of full of dead flies that I can
eat whenever I want and I still command
a a a group of dogs that are that I've
raised on my own but they're little
spider dogs G whiz I don't know that was
great thank you very much I think it
went
well thank you moving on well holy [__]
I have created an astonishing
partnership with mind Bloom you know
there's no quick fix for anxiety Andor
depression believe me I know uh you can
you know you can do your exercise you
can do your daily meditations and
practice gratitude you can change your
diet you can do talk therapy all of
these things are wonderful take it from
me but sometimes you need something
something to change your thinking unlock
things for you and Forge A New Path
perhaps for you that may be ketamine
therapy with mind Bloom there's a new
tool to improve your mental health atome
ketamine therapy mind Bloom is the
leader in at home ketamine therapy
having safely helped thousands of people
overcome their anxiety and depression
unlike traditional talk therapy ketamine
Works quickly and doesn't have the
unpleasant side effects of traditional
anti-depressants in a study of over
1,200 mind Bloom clients 89% reported
improvements in their anxiety and
depression after only two sessions right
now mind Bloom is offering our listeners
$100 off your first six sessions uh
program when you sign up at mind
bloom.com
dudy and use the promo code dudy take
the first step and break free from your
anxiety and depression with mind Bloom
mind bloom.com dudy and use promo code
dudy I've created an astonishing
partnership with Harry's you know
something you may not know about me is
that I am a professional actor by trade
Chad did you know that what he had no
clue and when you're acting you're in
front of the camera those things are 4K
8K 72k you can see every little nicking
flya away hair and red little bump on
your neck you don't want any of that
that's why I choose Harry's that way
when I shave down I can put my best foot
forward and putting your best foot
forward means putting your best face
forward no matter why you shave Harry's
has you covered for the best shave of
your life at a price that you'll love
like when you get this this is the
starter set that's the starter set that
is the starter set that starter set is a
$13 value that you can pick up for just
$3 right now at harry's.com
sdy it includes a five blade German
engineered razor weighted handle foaming
shave J
and travel cover scheduled delivery for
refills as low as $2 that's half of what
you pay for other blades get your best
shave ever with Harry's razors and skin
products you're going to get that $13
starter set for just $3 right now
harry's.com dudy that's harry's.com dudy
for a $3 starter
[Music]
set um G whiz uh the [__] doing an
impression as someone else as a an
impression what's going on with your mic
I don't know dude it keeps it's ghosting
yeah it's the
ghost only two more segments until
today's segment of the week for the
first time in history AI negotiated a
contract autonomously without any human
help or input yes dude a company called
luminance developed an AI called
autopilot that successfully negotiated a
non-disclosure agreement in a matter of
minutes a task that can take human
beings months Chad I know you read all
about this and I'm curious to know your
take on how AI is going to affect the
legal system in the near future this is
noich chattis AI law begin interesting
my pleasure so yes what happened was
this company has this uh AI product
called autopilot that can negotiate
certain legal
documents most of what lawyers do I
repeat most of what all lawyers do is
paperwork it's reading documents
and then synthesizing new documents
contract negotiation is a part of it if
you're in that type of law certainly we
have entertainment attorneys their
entire job is contract negotiation
that's all it is you get a contract from
a studio a network a streamer whatever
and then you go back and forth with
their legal department and your lawyers
saying give me more money or these
things or whatever uh in this case it
was negotiating a non-disclosure
agreement you know professional actor
how long can it take to get these
contracts negotiating sometimes
well anytime I've been handed an NDA
it's because I'm being given a script
that no one's supposed to talk about yet
sure uh contract like that I would have
no idea how I mean that seems pretty
standard but uh in entertainment but
like when you're doing brand deals and
[__] the ndas from those Brands can be
quite extensive specif and if you're a
big like a celebrity who's doing like a
Pepsi commercial or something going back
and forth between the celebrities
lawyers and the Pepsi Co or Fredo I
guess is Pepsi that can take uh weeks
months I'm always I will say this I'm
always Blown Away by how long this [__]
takes same yeah yeah you'll sell
something in quotes like on the writing
side you'll sell a movie or something or
get a job to write a movie and it's
[__] a month and a half two months
sometimes later before you get commenced
to start that job because it takes that
long for lawyers to go back and forth
doing these contracts so these AIS were
were able to do this negotiation in a
matter of literal
minutes saving months of work right oh
[__] that's said what is the impact of
this is the first time we're really
seeing this in the legal field where AI
is being brought in and essentially just
wiping out the need for humans to do
this type of Labor this negotiating
labor so what does that mean in the
legal field is what dudy asked me it
means I think largely most law will be
performed by AIS with a human being
serving as the overseer to read through
the final document present that to your
client whoever that may be and clearly
they still have to sign it a human being
will have to sign these documents
whatever legal documents they may be in
order to uh make them final that will
always be the case but I think the grunt
work of the negotiations and the
generating of these contracts is going
to largely be done by AIS which
means the entire legal field is going to
be drastically changed oh come on now
this is this is where I take issue I
don't please yeah I I don't think take
the issue dude I'm gonna take the issue
where are you taking it I'm taking it to
you bring it I'm here I'm ready to
receive your issue yeah you my first
issue is you always say [__] like this
and what I don't like about it what and
I'm always right yeah and Chad's I would
describe you kind of as a bit of a
futurist is that fair fair to say I'm a
humanist and uh when you when you sure
sure you can be both there's no rule
against that all I'm saying is this this
is a big weird world we're living in
more than ever
and uh the more that you can uh
prioritize people and I you could put
this towards any any subject in the
world or anything that's going on right
now we talk about you know what the
thing what's the thing or the thing is
being a lawyer the thing is having these
contracts made here's you know uh real
estate law here's entertainment law
here's uh family law these are all just
these are things these are ideas what's
most important is people and if you're
if you're taking taking away
someone's and I mean this in the most
arbitrary way whatever their job is
whatever their their their life force is
someone wants to be a [__] lawyer and
now you're saying knock everybody out
it's only AI yeah and I'm I know I'm
looking at this in a very rudimentary
way what if somebody wakes up and is
like I want to drive a horse and
carriage and you're like oh but we have
cars now yeah you can go drive a horse
and carriage you can go pursue that
you're not going to make any money at it
it's not a viable career anymore because
technology has eliminated it technology
eliminates labor that is all that it has
ever done since the the dawn of
technology that is continuing now the
labor happens to be law and if you're a
person who can't afford an
attorney you're going to have an app
that will do your contracts for you that
will look through any legal thing you
have and suggest this is what I think
you should do it'll be up to you as a
person to make that decision to sign the
contract or not but I think AI legal
council will exist for everyone in the
form of an app that's pretty cheap and I
actually think that's a good thing no
that is a good thing and there have been
uh companies and apps that have tried to
do that before you know them if you know
them uh that sounds good anything that's
that makes things easier is good I'm
just saying as a humanist you know part
of it is let's what do people want to do
to me that's more important than
anything and J not not just as a job
what do people want from the people
doing the job I don't know that people
at this point maybe in the amount of
time that has spanned from the Horseless
Carriage or the horse and carriage
rather to now maybe in a 100 years
people be like lawyers what's that
you'll have to crack a history book to
even figure out what the [__] that is it
won't it won't be something that people
uh need but right now yeah [__] it all
right have your [__] AI La people
make the laws basically the entire legal
field is split into the various kinds
contract law corporate law there's
litigators there's criminal law etc etc
all of this [__] is based on judgments
from prior cases so when you're arguing
a case whatever it may be in any of
these situations you're literally just a
[__] database of Prior cases and how
you can leverage those judgments against
whatever the situation may be your
that's true and that's a bunch of dumb
work and that's what costs people money
okay you know what you know what Nostra
chattis you actually turn me a little
bit on this
one I was kind of yeah I don't I don't
even agree I don't agree with what the
[__] I said earlier and that's and
that's that was quick yeah well that's
the power of dudy but I'm going to ask
you this we just uh very recently and
this is great news um you know uh for me
and for you and uh you know anyone that
likes to watch television the SAG strike
is over dude that's a great example sag
stripe WJ strike these are [__] four
and five month long strikes yeah get
some AIS in there over in a day I'm
[__] down all right you know what and
I'm not just saying this because again
I'm not just saying this cuz I'm trying
to Curry favor with d yeah but I agree
with this guy I agree with my pal Chow
over here cuz the human element in those
[__] strikes and the negotiations is
what [__] it up you have people being
like well I'm not taking that I'm
walking out of this [__] meeting and
now it's a week before we simmer down
and can finally meet face to face again
AIS are 24/7 negotiate negotiate
negotiate and then you can look at the
negotiation if you're the head of the
wga or the head of the mptp you look at
what the negotiations are and you say
this is good this is bad
we will
some it's just a simpler way of that
reques less time it's efficiency uh and
and law is probably the first such thing
that is going to go by the wayside this
Health Care would be good dude that's
already happening for sure you're going
to have an app whatever whoever provides
your health insurance let's say it's
Kaiser Perman you're going to have your
Kaiser app there's going to be an AI on
it that is essentially your your general
doctor if you need like a prescription
if you need some kind of lowlevel
uh medication or um diagnosis you're
going to take a picture of some [__]
weird spot on your leg the AI is going
to be like that's Gang Green cut your
leg off not really but it's going to
diagnose these these smaller things that
don't require you to like call up a
doctor get the [__] doctor's
appointment go in and see the doctor
blah blah blah blah blah and my spinner
rat is making yellow
silk I think that happens actually I
feel like [__] and my spinnerette is
blowing out chunks of dead fly yeah well
hey you know what if he may if if he may
I I think I think you're right about
that and if we could have done that with
the uh with the SAG after strike uh that
would have been great because just look
at it for [__] 7 seconds and we can
move on uh move on with our lives and
then we can all be obsolete as actors
too oh wait I don't want that the real
like skill of a human lawyer is tricking
the system is looking at the rules that
are in place the precedent that has been
set by prior case law and especially if
you're like a defense attorney it's
saying how can I spin this in my
client's favor to be like well this is
the spirit of the law versus the letter
of the law or whatever the the strategy
may be but really like the creative
element of law does come from humans and
I think that will still be there I think
you'll still have like highlevel human
attorneys who are you're going to want
them in defense trials you're going to
want them in uh prosecutions of highle
type clients and stuff like that but I
think the basic grunt workk of all law
or anything that is uh has heavily to do
with documents is going to be done by
AIS well you know it's bad news for
those of us who really enjoyed the
Johnny Depp Amber herd
trial
nice thank you moving
on you know what else is going Chad as
always you're 100% correct about the
future integration of technology and law
now let's discuss a little place called
dudy store.com it's your One-Stop shop
for the new dudy
unless you shop at tiffy's because now
with any purchase of a dudy logo t-shirt
from tiffy's and Company you get a free
sandwich bag full of diamonds and
because you got to have something to put
those diamonds in you can also pick up a
good job boner mug at dudy store.com too
nice and you still have a little more
time to put in your pre-orders for
dude's evening Stout to make sure you
get it by dude's evening unfortunately
the store manager of Tiffany's New York
isn't here to give you the details about
the diamonds because he's busy shooting
his new movie the wizard man but he did
send us a trailer let's take a look am I
the wizard man well let's see did I
single-handedly slay the twin ice
dragons of powder Veil Lake yes I did am
I the wizard man well let's see did I
single-handedly defend the castle of
camor from an undead army yes I did am I
the wizard man well let's see did I
transform myself into a giant in order
to single-handedly rescue the princess
and her fiance from a hive of angry
thund th Titans who wanted to put them
in a goddamn stew yes I did am I the
wizard man well let's see even though
I'm not a blacksmith did I Forge the ark
blade because I'm the only person in the
realm who can channel that much fell
energy without burning to a crisp yes I
did so yeah I'm the [__] wizard
man now who the [__] are
you he knows who he is do you you ever
touch my staff again I'll break your
[__] hands
capiche okay hey
an intense Tom ha this week the wizard
man the wizard
man oh my God the wizard man well let's
see well let's see he's very shit's
intent on making sure that you
understand he's The Wiz the wizard man
am I the wizard man let's see he's going
to break your [__] hand
touches okay I want to see the wizard
man so bad I want to see I can't wait to
see I need a double feature of of the
Darby 1 and Darby 2 and then I'm going
to need to see some Uncle bus and I'm
going to need to see some wizard man and
[__] wizard man dude oh boy anyway
hey if you're enjoying today's episode
please make sure to subscribe on YouTube
we're at about 63k right now we're on
our march to 100K please join us there
and uh hit the notification Bell when
you're there uh make sure to like the
episode And subscribe across uh all P
podcast platforms make sure uh to leave
a comment we're going to get into that
with you want to leave a comment cuz
we're going to you know we're going to
we're going to read some of those dude
yeah dude there's so much idiotic [__]
happening on Instagram dudy pod show
holy [__] go check it out new stuff from
Saria fre arama all of the incredible uh
folks out there our audience of of of
people who enjoy dudy as much as we do
great memes a lot of people took the
picture that I presented last week of my
mom feeding the horse and just [__]
ran wild with it yeah that [__] was
making me cry I was laughing so hard and
My Dead Body underneath the Hollywood
Sign has made it way into all sorts of
stuff go see what the Peter Diaz on
Instagram is doing thank you so much to
our pods pal dudy for making uh all of
that stuff and we are on Facebook and
Tik Tok all at those that handle the at
dudy pod show thanks to everybody who
has subscribed at dudy plus we like to
call it dudy plus patreon.com dudy s
bucks a month get you absolutely
everything that we do on dudy plus a
brand new episode of dudy after dudy
after every show you know just keeps
going you [__] watch more show a ton
more show seven bucks a month gets you
that seven bucks a month gets you all
our watch alongs like the Royal Rumble
1992 watch along dude that was so much
[__] fun I that Ric Flair flop I like
will never forget it yeah I'll never
forget how [__] funny that was yeah
it's [__] insane we watched the Royal
Rumble from 19 from 1992 Ric Flair runs
the board and go I can't even just get
it you don't need to queue anything up
you don't need to [__] sync this with
that it's all at dudy plus
patreon.com dudy and uh of course uh
there's an audio version of all the
episodes when you're on dudy plus if
that's what you like to do and it's ad
free ad free uh dudy plus that's how
that works please uh share the show all
over the damn place and uh on the
internet we would really appreciate that
and with that the show will grow and
follow Chad's new suggestion of what is
it exactly that you want people to do
with watching the show the show you
answer a question with a question if
someone asks you a question any question
at all you simply say I'd love to answer
that question but first I need to ask
you a question what did you think of the
most recent episode of dudy and if they
have no answer for that if they don't
know what dudy is you simply walk away
saying I'll answer your question when
you answer mine and you leave it at that
make makes a lot of sense to me okay so
there's all sorts of stuff to do hitting
subscriptions notifications uh the like
button and the like uh I would like to
give you a moment right now uh to do all
of that so uh please we'll give you a
moment uh to do that and then and then
we'll we'll be right back welcome back I
would also like to say we're in the
podcast era a lot of people doing
podcasts now love to see it it's one of
my favorite art forms that's ever been
devised by humanity and if you are doing
this art form if you have a podcast and
you want a guest on that podcast I'd be
happy to be that guest all you have to
do is send an email to book chadult
gmail.com I answer them in the order
received I do three appearances every
Saturday 20-minute increments 10: a.m.
to 10:20 a.m. PST 10:20 to 10:40 10:40
to11 uh like I said answer them in the
order received there's about a 5 month
queue right now but put your email uh in
there if you want to uh have me on your
podcast eventually I've been doing this
for a couple months now absolutely
loving it getting to see all the
different people's podcasts all the pods
out there what kind of stuff they're
doing it's a blast it's amazing it's
amazing that you're doing it uh Leave It
To My Pal Chow to hit that every [__]
week he's doing three podcasts yeah no
matter who they are love it and uh Chad
that's disgusting please don't burp into
the mic for our Audio Only uh audience
everyone knows that's you
everyone so there's also comments on the
internet let's uh let's read some
comments this week I am going to be
reading uh a couple comments here from
our aforementioned watchalong that we
had the 1992 ra all Rumble we thing and
hear some comments that were on uh on
the thing uh this is at Jacob Perry uh
commenting on dudy plus says as someone
who's never watched wrestling or
anything or anything he's never he's
never seen a screen no never watched
never watched anything as someone who's
never watched wrestling or anything I'm
really enjoying these smoke sessions
with you guys it doesn't matter what it
is you choose to watch I just enjoy
hearing your high
talk well tune in to dudy after dudy cuz
that also happens there we we smoked a
couple of joints uh while we watched the
RO Rumble
1992 and it it got off the had to be
done we had a lot of fun simply had to
okay and uh this one is from Alex McBeth
who says I want to see leev shriber as
Jake Roberts in a movie of course Chad
there's that movie The Iron Claw coming
out yeah with Jeremy Allen White and uh
the other guy and all that stuff that's
going to be cool the other guy Zack
Efron Zack Efron yes that's well that's
not the other guy I was thinking about
of course Zach Zachary Efron's in the
movie Efron you mean yeah that guy this
would be good maybe this starts a trend
of you know some of our finest actors
right as wrestlers do you remember any
uh Million dooll Man the do you remember
the million-dollar man promo actually
the the the Jake The Snake Million dooll
Man promo I only really remember one
because you used to always play it on
TMP oh yeah yeah yeah I am going to make
you beg
dbsi this time you're the one who's
going to be humiliated this time you'll
be the one who's humbled and this time
you will be the one graveling for the
money and isn't it
appropriate that the very money you
gravel for is your own a victim of your
own greed
wallowing in the muck of avarice
Wordsworth couldn't have said it better
himself put that cigarette out okay this
one is from uh thank you sjobs 911 I
used to be such a big fan of the WWF
brother this is way more fun that I
expected and I had High Hopes thanks D
yeah that's great I'm glad people were
like I really I loved it it was so much
[__] fun watching that dude it's just
it's one of the craziest spectacles I
think that I've ever seen yeah uh on any
level the flare flop man the flare flop
he it's just the [__] it's just it
was so entertaining so much uh storyline
built into that Royal Rumble the Macho
Man wanted to get a Jake the Snake
Roberts we covered in the show for
sinking uh snake's uh teeth right into
the Macho Man Hulk wanted to get it Sid
Justice Rody Piper wanted to get it Ric
Flair of course the Macho Man and Ric
Flair they had history Carrie von Eric
the modern day Warrior uh the Texas
tornado as they called him man I could
go on and on but I don't have to because
we already did stoned as [__] and Chad's
going back in his mind to when this
happened and I like to talk about
wrestling and we sure did it on uh on
this past Friday on dudy plus you know
my segment of the week is up next but
before we get to that we got to discuss
something shalam hosted Saturday Night
Live it was his second time hosting but
the first time since becoming Wonka you
two are different in many ways and yet
similar in many more I was happy to
learn that you both tuned in and watched
the entire show I'm dying to know what
you thought of Wonka's performance this
is shalam Night Live begin ah okay W let
me just say this about one Saturday
Night Live I have seen up until about
six or seven years years ago I'd seen
every episode many of them as they aired
like I was a religious viewer of that
show uh I really thought that it was
kind of like The Benchmark for where TV
comedy was and obviously people were
popping out of that show to do sitcoms
and movies and [__] all the time um and
really a lot of the people that came off
that show defined certain eras of Comedy
for Real uh you're looking at like Eddie
Murphy Chevy Chase even up through like
will feral and [__] I would say you know
fck just defining it but I haven't
watched it in a in a bit and this was
the first episode I've seen in probably
like six or seven years really what that
long yeah you know a couple of things
got me back in Saturday Night Live a few
years ago because there was a long
period of time when I where I didn't
watch it uh one was our our good pal
Taran killum sure being in the cast for
six years I was so stoked to see him
there I loved what he did uh my buddy
Melissa via seor being on the show show
and now more recently our good buddy
Mike diva is directing uh some of the
some of the most interesting [__] on the
show sort of the the pre-tape segment
the you know the you know I'm just Pete
like the the just Ken uh thing with Pete
um Davidson that he just did incredible
[__] and so it's brought me back in you
brought me back into to sort of watching
the show a while back and uh so I've
been checking out the show over the past
couple years on and off and it was very
interesting to see TC Timothy shalam on
the show I've but I got to say this as
much as we talk about Timothy shalam on
the show and did you know Chad that
shalam is
Wonka
shalam is Wonka And if you don't if you
don't understand that shalam is Wonka
maybe yeah and you checked out you
watched s Night Live over the or shalam
Night Live as dudy says over the weekend
you understand now that shalam hold on
dude sham
is Wonka but but that movie hasn't come
out yet and I've only seen Timothy
shalam in uh don't look up and I and uh
was he in that oh and um yeah he was
like the weird hippie guy yeah and I
think that I think that's it I've seen
him in that and I've seen him in Dune
and I've seen him in a movie called
Bones and all where he was just a guy
who eats people uh not a zombie just a
guy who eats people MH this this what he
did here in this
episode he want
look I almost burped but I won't and I
won't blame it on you thank you all
right oh man I got some gas oh my
spinnerette so there it
is here's what here's what I want to say
about shalam on Center life he looked
like he was having a [__] great time
absolutely was he ever Charming dude
I'll tell you what this did for me with
Shel I've only seen him in serious roles
You could argue I guess don't look up as
was kind of comedic yeah but not that
movie is not like a comedy I would say
it's maybe a satire if anything right uh
this performance on S live made me want
to see him as a lead in a comedy yes I
think he could do it yeah uh he he was
giggling at himself the whole time kind
of like an old like kind of you know
smiling out the side of his face like
yeah I'm doing the show but I'm also
having a good time like like Bill Murray
of old used to do and like Keenan
Thompson does now kind of there but
having a great time which is I think
important for the host of the show and I
think he he
really some of the [__] that he did uh
like uh what in particular did he do the
Donald Trump at the beginning no James
Austin Johnson did that let me give uh a
dudy salute to James Austin Johnson one
of the absolute finest impersonators
you I got to say they put him in
Prosthetics to make him look more like
Trump I think that was a mistake I think
you put a blonde wig on him and you let
him do his thing I think the facial
Prosthetics hurt the impression actually
well you know uh I I don't consider
myself an impressionist as you know we
covered that earlier on the show but I
am a professional actor by trade so
completing that illusion is something
that I that I quite enjoy but uh what
else did uh what else did TC do oh he
did that sketch where he was a rapper
that was funny the monologue dude was
Wonka he came out and basically said
like the actor strike is over so I can
promote my movie and he started singing
a song called Shameless self-promotion
Liv in a world of Shameless selfpromo
did you see then there was an AI joke
yeah the AI joke was weak and they made
another AI joke later as well in the
show I think joking about AI at least in
my opinion it just shows a lack of
understanding of basic reality and where
humanity is headed well I think it's f
he also did that when he was that yeah
that rapper drip splash water splash
splash drip drip that was good he looked
like he was having a good time in that
yeah uh the the uh the what else uh was
he in Weekend Update no TC in The
Weekend Update was barely interested in
it and normally My Weekend Update is
that's the I'm always want to check out
we I think that TC in your [__] show
use TC he should have been in every
sketch and he should played multiple
characters in every sketch he could have
played Colin Jost and Michael Chay in uh
Weekend Update no that's silly but did
you did you see on Weekend Update if I
may if I if I may if I may uh they
covered that Jared Leto climbing Empire
State Building yes I did see that yeah
what the [__] was that about what do you
think of that what do you think is going
on there I think look I think there's
certain actors Prof professional actors
once they start hitting a certain age
they feel very compelled to prove that
they can still do crazy physical [__]
Tom Cruz is another one he's like
flipping motorcycles off the side of a
mountain and [__] for real flying jet
planes for real he's 60 years old he's
showing [__] it it doesn't matter and I
think Leto is doing some kind of similar
thing he's 50 now I think yeah some
something like that and he's like [__]
this I can still climb a building and
I'll use it to promote my album or tour
or whatever the [__] he do promoting the
the the the the 30 Seconds to Mars yeah
but here's if I if if I may if I may
sure that wasn't Jared letto what that
wasn't Jared Leto climbing the building
yeah why the [__] would they let D let
me tell you something about Jared
[__] letto that [__] guy hey I'm
[__] driving over the [__]
Queensboro and I [__] look up and I
see [__] to my left I go whoa who's
that beautiful broad climbing the empire
we F hey it must be the sequel to King
Kong now because you know King Kong's
the sensitive one and the woman's the
hero the woman's going to reach into
building and grab grab King Kong out and
go who swatting away the
planes but no it was that beautiful uh
galetto [__] not a [__] chance
that was that was probably I'm going to
say Tom Cruz and a wig he came down from
the empire a it's all on video and B he
came down and did a Good Morning America
appearance immediately after it so that
was all fake immediately after it yeah
yeah he [__] one guy went down and
Tom and Tom Cruz SL it
was anyway whatever and then there was
that other sketch with what was this
Troy Savon [__] I've never Molly my
wonderful wife Molly she knew who there
was a sketch about Troy Savon with the
brilliant boow and yang and Sarah wor
whom I love uh what what the [__] was
that about what is I know Troy saon what
is that what's going on there just a pop
singer I know troyon because I'm a huge
fan of Charlie XCX and they did a song
together called 1999 maybe like a year
or two ago well that's going to be on my
on my listen list speaking of listen
list uh boy Genius was on the show they
were great didn't know him pretty good
liked them I'm I'm new to boy Genius uh
I really liked uh that and uh TC was in
those cuz he had to in them overall it
was a TC TCS show uh and then Alec
Baldwin was in the end and showed up did
did his duty I just got to say My
overall takeaway from it is I want to
see more TC I want to see more it did
its job he got me hyped up for Wonka and
he got me hyped up for whatever he's
going to do next I became a legitimate
TC fan because of this I feel yeah I'm
getting tced out uh I'm excited for
Wonka and and uh you know episodes of s
night live over the years you can kind
of interchange them all and stuff but
this is a special episode like when
Charles Barkley would host
[Music]
yeah thank you moving
on that was not Jared
Leto oh I'm on one today yeah you know
I'll tell you this we made it the
segment of the week will I just want to
thank you so much for sending me your
new self Tronics document for my
thoughts it meant a lot to me and I just
wanted to let you know that I really
only had one thought I absolutely loved
it would you be so kind as to read your
new chronics document to everyone right
now if it's something you decide to do
then I feel very honored to present
chronics whenever you're ready champ
this is Champ Tronics begin you got it D
champ Tronics uh something I've been
hang on hang on don't give me all right
so you're sending D more [__] outside
the scope of the show you're just like
here's an email [__] emailed the you
[__] did that you did that before I
did all right I'm just laying the cards
out on the table okay so you've done
that now every week pretty much since
you got in the belt no no no no no no
what do you mean some kind of extra
thing you sent him the video from
Uh Oh YouTube from Winnipeg yeah yeah uh
now you're sending this new document
which is called
chronics yep but it's not yeah all right
okay all right okay you don't I'm I'm
not liking or disliking I'm just trying
to get the facts let me open my uh
trying to assess the situation uhhuh
uhhuh yeah assist situation yeah uhhuh
yeah some days somebody's going to hold
you down and make you cry uhuh till then
baby are you going to let it something
something make you cry yeah crying
thinking dying no way you got to hold on
for one more day oh
yeah yeah dude that's performative
coughing brother yep listen Chad let's
hear some chronics please fine I'll just
get into it please as you know I have
authored a uh self-help system many
years ago that I am still working on to
bring uh to publish as a uh book it's um
it's based on my own experience it was
the summer of 2008 I was I was sitting
there on the beach I was in Venice and I
was just sort of um having a sort of a a
mental egoic
uh metamorphosis I think and uh 10day
metamorphosis you were on day five yeah
I was turning into a spider yeah and I
was sitting there saying to myself I'm
halfway to becoming a spider how do I
get the full way there can I walk on the
water there's tepid waves that smell
like poo poo I'm in Venice I'm not going
to jump in but I was looking at the
water going you know I'm [__] up my
shit's [__] up and I I need some
Tronics since then I have been working
on the the book self Tronics and the
self-help system that I've
offered that I've authored you know and
um this is a different thing yes this is
this is chronics and it's something
because look
I've been struggling with a lot of the
things that sort of led me to create uh
self Tronics in the first place okay
yeah how is Champ Tronics different from
self Tronics well I'm going to get into
that please as as I as
anytime I look I I I Jesus Christ we all
have problems in life and I you know I
got this and that and I got some mental
things I got the got this sort of
depression and that kind of thing and
all this [__] and we could talk about
that more in dudy after dudy if you
really want to get [__] bummed out
but I thought to myself that I need to
take self Tronics to the next level okay
champ Tronics okay so if I may so these
are Tronics from the mind of a champ
basically is that what we're getting at
yeah it's champ it's sort of like it's a
mindset stuff like you could just like
watch How To Be A Champion type thing
yeah yeah like you know on Instagram and
Tik Tok YouTube it's all the mindset
[__] that's all [__] this is like
useful stu okay yeah let's it um all
right here's what I've written this is
what I got so far I'm sort of starting
out with chronics I am now your
Undisputed uh dude's the episode
Champion so it's a new thing for me hey
your shit's [__] up huh you're [__]
up and your shit's [__] up your shit's
all [__] up these last few years have
been so [__] up that almost everyone's
[__] has been [__] up lots of us are
[__] up we need a new mindset a
Champions mindset okay champ Tronics is
an all new set of Tronics that will help
you become a champion and get your [__]
unfucked up
okay uh I've got uh 11 Tronics here
Jesus that I would like to share okay
well all right let's do it oh [__] okay
so number one no complaints Champions
never complain ever did you know that
Chad yeah I agree with that you know
recently I was talking to Tom Brady he's
a good friend of mine
and uh I asked him how he's how he was
doing and he said no complaints and I
was like oh all right cool like what's
up why why not I was curious as a good
friend of mine that sure he's your best
friend I've heard and he said uh he said
you know I'm a champion no complaints
which brings me to my second chronics
okay it's a very important one yeah
number two be a champion in every
[Music]
adversity what that's a champ Tron
favorite one
Be A Champion well [__] just be a
champion do you don't let me you don't
understand the whole Tronics of it all
and how these things they may seem those
first two real well pretty easy to
understand all right in every adversity
there's a championship waiting for you
to take it for me it was when dudy
brought in the episode Champion concept
okay I felt like I wasn't a champion and
I had a close friend who was a champion
while I was happy for him and felt he
was deserving I was also like he's not
that great this is Tom
Brady yeah I knew I had to become a
champion To Be A Champion okay in my
head I was like [__] that [__] I'm
already a champion then dudy sent a
championship belt to my close friend and
I got [__] up again but then something
happened I won the dudy episode
Championship hello hello hello hello
number three progress
progress is nothing without risk rest
the latter part of the word progress
sounds a lot like rest Champions don't
rest they risk pretty self-explanatory
that's pretty good I like that one
actually hello hi all right uh number
three disappear for a while I know what
you're thinking you know there's already
there was already a third champ Tronics
okay that's true I I there's two threes
because if you do this one direct ly or
correctly rather it'll disappear okay
okay you will be rewarded in public for
what you do in private for some that's
working on something dedicating all your
time to it yes get back in the lab as
they say whether that's getting in shape
improving your home just generally
getting your [__] together so you'll
disappear and do that [__] and when you
reappear everyone's like whoa holy [__]
right but sometimes you disappear and
you still don't do
[__] okay don't worry so long as you've
disappeared for a while people will
still notice that you've been gone and
even the shitty stuff that you did
before and are still doing will seem
different because it's been a while and
those people might think that you've
improved even though you haven't [__]
done [__] but this will actually buy you
time to disappear again and uh and
please do the [__] this time you [__]
idiot right okay sure okay number
four give up to go
up this is similar to there was a old
the give down yeah okay right got it
okay uh in the old self Tronics we had
the give down still a great Tronics but
also there's some [__] you need to give
up before you can go up so figure out
what that [__] is and give it up so you
can go up then when you're a champion
and you're all the way up there maybe
you can give some stuff down this is
chronics yeah number five yawn in their
face when someone says you can't do
something say oh I'm going to yawn in
your face and then go like
this now what okay number six spoon in
the road fork in the road [__] that [__]
there's a spoon in the road when you're
met with two choices let me see it use
your spoon your spoon to Dig A New Path
right between those two choices make a
third road with a spoon no spoon in the
road okay number seven opposite day
you're a [__] loser all right you
don't know [__] and what
this is a self-help system that I've
authored Chad so it's tough love
sometimes
okay you're a [__] loser you yeah
actually when I hear that again it does
it is a little bit it's a little harsh
yeah yeah you're a writer have you ever
written a self-help book uh I've been
working on for a long time called the
pattern the [__] pattern yeah dude
eventually it will come out yeah
eventually self Tronics will come out
great do you want to have a race no yeah
all right yeah mine's going to come out
tomorrow it's not true I have a lot of
work still to do on it but yes I'm
writing one yeah I'll read this as as
written you're a [__] loser you you
don't know [__] and you [__] everything
up if you're a shitty loser you get a
holiday every day opposite day every
choice you're met with do the opposite
maybe that'll unfuck things Loser yeah
it's not it is a little abrasive eight
skill will and chill you need three
things to be a champion you need the
skill which can be developed if you
don't have it um I was recently I was
talking to my friend Tom Brady and uh I
said to him how' you meet Tom Brady and
I said uh Tom you you have uh how are
you so good at what you do and do you
know what he said H you know what's the
quality he has
will yeah but also skill oh number two
you'll need the will fortunately for me
that's my name but there's also another
will hold on dude there's two Wills dude
but this ain't Hulk Tronics dude this is
chronics and then you need to chill
because what are you going to do just
kick the [__] out of life all the time
even Tom Brady chills out and smokes
joint and watches reality TV or beats
off and falls asleep sometimes that one
needs a little that one might need a
little massage yeah I don't know if Tom
Brady would want you uh you know talking
about his personal behaviors like this
yeah we we ran into problems with that
before yeah yeah Tom Brady almost sued
us before that's right yeah he sent us a
cease and assist and that was not put
together by AI lawyers not yet nope it
was some guys that were [__] in touch
with us and O you know and then dudy
went off and started calling him
football baby and all hell bro broke
loose number nine stay parallel they say
the company that you are the company
that you keep and it's true get around
Champions and be around them but that's
not enough you need to be parallel I
want to say something real quick before
we continue yeah I don't know if you're
realizing What's Happening Here what
when we began this program you refuse to
do many of the things dudy would ask you
to do uh simple things make a vegan
dessert you'd say [__] that I'm not
doing it I have free will speaking of
your skill will and chill yeah now now
dudy made this belt and is getting you
to do extra work putting into the show
making little videos sending little
messages you have written an entire
segment for dudy and are now performing
it still free will you are doing dudy
job for dudy dudy has you doing labor
into this show for dudy we're dudy okay
yeah I know what you're [__] doing
but that's not what what I'm doing yes
okay it's me okay it's [__] I'm oh oh
I'm so sorry I've never done self
Tronics before oh I've never had that in
my the only difference between having
this [__] in my computer and what's
happening today is that I sent it to D
yeah self Tronics is a great example
self Tronics is a segment that dudy
found in your hard drive pulled out of
it and said why don't you read this
you're now writing that segment and
sending it to dudy Y no number nine stay
parallel they say you are the company
that you keep and it's true get around
Champions and be around them but that's
not enough yeah stay parallel you got to
get parallel
okay now I I'm parallel right now with
my great friend Chad he's a hardworking
guy he's a great partner on the podcast
and someone uh that I respect Watch What
Happens watch what happens when I do
this Chad
I'm going to hand you this belt all
right
okay there's a champion I'm giving him
the belt for there it is and I'm going
to take it back if that's all right
sure you see that no what parallel all
right number 10 excuses versus dreams
equation you need to
have the excuses versus dreams equation
okay how does that work well you need
what is the equation you can you write
it down I did and it's very simple and
I've cracked it by myself and I just
wanted to share it with everybody here
but he he's oh it's against the
rules the rules and do all the things
there are no rules here clearly clearly
you can do whatever you want I'm just
saying I want you to recognize that you
have changed dramatically the amount of
effort that you're putting to the show
and you are indeed now even doing free
work into the
show listen man I'm not going to change
your [__] mind you think what you
want about me okay you think what you
want about me I feel good about myself
now I got something to hold on
to there's a lot of problems in my life
but I got something now right okay look
dude that's great I mean but you know I
would I would encourage you to go back
and watch the video of this when it airs
and watch yourself clutching that belt
just see what you think of what that
image is
like number 10 excuses versus dreams
equation yeah you need to have here's
your [__] equation more dreams than
excuses two dreams you're allowed one
excuse okay that's good one dream no
excuses it's good to maybe start with
three or four dreams so you can have a
couple excuses but try to get it down to
one dream come on this is chronics don't
be a [__] again the tough love Yeah 11
uh and finally uh our last 11
unofficially 12 cuz there were two
number threes sure whoa one of them
already disappeared number 11 what is
chronics that's a stupid question and
it's a great question that's a stupid
question if you can't figure that out no
amount of chronics will help you no one
owes you [__] I don't owe you any more
champ
Tronics who are you yelling at I'm
trying to
motivate no one owes you [__] I'm
reading
this okay I don't owe you any more champ
Tronics go make your own Tronics get
those Tronics if you're a chef get those
Chef Tronics if you're a musician get
those musician Tronics if you're a
speech pathologist get those speech
pathologist Tronics hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello hello
hello this pretty
good thank you moving on I got to say
overall I liked it oh thank you very
much not bad episode 81's in the books
you both left it all on the field for
your impressive efforts you've been
awarded 83 total points bringing that
cumulative score to
7,619 you're just
2381 points away from the great
Revelation at 10,000 points this week
we're going back to the wrestling and
Anime Well Chad you really seem to enjoy
Ric Flair in last week's 1992 Royal
Rumble watch along which is available
now only on dudy Plus at patreon.com
dudy so I want you to continue your
astonishing fandom of the legendary
Nature Boy with the one and only Ric
Flair versus Sting from the very first
Clash of the Champions back in
1988 and will I'm going to see if I can
interest you in an incredible new
animated show on Max called scavengers
check out the First episodes and we'll
discuss next week thank you so much for
joining us week until next week call me
dud Z I am so envious of you that you
get to watch this incredible match
between the Stinger sting and I can't
wait I'm I'm super hyped to watch some
more Rick Flair and I'm very curious to
see what you think about scavengers
reain I've watched uh so far every
episode that's been put out and it is
mind-blowing I cannot wait to watch
these three episodes
dudy
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah hey dudy After dudy Time hats off
to you what do you
mean you wrote a segment and you sent it
to [__] give me a [__] break hey
I'm no harm no foul hats off to you
champ strategy
valid hey welcome to dudy after dudy you
know what I mean my buddy Chad here is
on one today cuz he's has no idea what
free will is I can't just bring self
Tronics or there therefore chronics to
the people hats off to okay anyway you
know it's that part of the show where
things just kind of get a little more
mellow I'm going to chill out we might
get into some gabis and we'll see what
dudy has to say about not being here at
all while I hold on to this title
hopefully for the rest of my natural
[__] life Welcome to dudy after dudy
the Flagship weekly show of dudy plus
you can join us at patreon.com dudy well
I have to say I think both of you pushed
yourselves to the Limit and Beyond today
thank you for everything I'm going to go
get my tabin started I'll be back with
your final numbers and the announcement
of this week's episode champion this is
dudy after dudy have some fun with
it that I will dud is getting his tabin
started yeah get that Tab and started
dude something that I did not mention
during the what it Timothy shom Night
Live live yeah during that segment I
didn't mention this uh but I I feel I
must I met shalam once you you [__]
you met shalam when when did you meet
shalam please tell a friend then
R if you like d what you
do please tell a friend then
aie if you like d here do